I actually I spent a bunch of time
analyzing and in reflecting on why it
was that we were even able to do it
because all like all reasons suggest
that we shouldn't have been able to do
it right because all these other
companies had way more engineering power
and servers and time and money and all
the stuff and I actually think that this
is a pretty instructive thing for
anything that you want to go do because
this is the same properties gonna be
true for anything that you guys start is
that someone else is gonna have more
resources the reason why I think we
actually ended up being the ones doing
it is because we just cared way more
about it than everyone else you know
early on there were always these
skeptics saying that aw this can't be a
business Whedon actually care that much
about it being a business early on but a
lot of the reason why bigger companies
didn't invest in it was because it
wasn't clear that there was a model that
would work for it and I actually think
that that's true for a lot of the best
ideas it's not that someone else can't
do it they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but I think often
that belief and the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day I actually
think a lot of the reason why great
stuff gets built is because it's kind of
irrational at the time but so it kind of
selects where the people who care the
most about it doing it the students
around me were really important both in
high school and in college and the
people who started Facebook with me and
a lot of people who are still with me
running the company today are people who
I met when I was at Harvard we had like
social bonds and academic bonds and I
just I won't understate the importance
of that and I mean it's very tied into
my whole philosophy and the product that
that I spend my life building Facebook
because we just believe that social
bonds are critical you just watched two
amazing clips of Mark Zuckerberg take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]